Shall we, future Mrs. G.?
I love you.
The detective knows
what I really am.
Are you alright?
-Do you need my help?
-Well, that's just it.
Apparently it seems
that she's fine with it.
Listen, detective.
What does it mean when a
woman recoils at your touch?
It means that they hate you.
Would you like to go out
with me this evening?
Every day he remains
on Earth,
people are in danger.
The devil must go back
to hell.
And the only person who
can send him there is you.
Lucifer!
-I'm sorry.
-Oh, sorry.
I didn't realise
I'd left it so loud.
I'll get it. No, I've got
it, detective. Don't worry.
Ow!
Damn.
How is it that sometimes
you don't get hurt
and then other times you do?
What is the difference?
I'm only vulnerable
when I'm close to you.
Detective, what's this?
-Nothing.
-Oh, right.
Well, if it's nothing,
you won't mind me
drinking it then, will you?
Don't drink it.
It's perfume.
I've had worse.
No, don't!
For a moment,
I was helping him try to
send you back to hell.
How could you do that to me?
To me?
Because I'm terrified!
You are the actual devil.
Could you accept me
like this?
I don't know.
Then I have my answer.
Tonight, we won,
but we just plucked one hole
in a very flimsy boat.
Now the demons know I've
no intention of returning,
they'll continue to defy me.
I see.
So, what are you saying?
I have to go back.
You were right.
About the prophecy.
We did get it wrong.
It is about hell coming
to Earth,
and we may have stopped it
now, but for how long?
I need to keep them
contained.
They must have a king.
Please don't go. I…
I love you.
We were wrong about
something else
in the prophecy.
My first love was never Eve.
It was you, Chloe.
It always has been.
Hello, detective.
It's really you.
How?
It's a funny story,
actually.
So, there I was in hell
and--
When I found out about this…
manipulation,
I felt the same way as you.
Then I realised that
it's far from a curse.
It's a gift.
There is
a huge difference, Lucifer.
You were given a gift.
I am that gift.
I want us to be together.
I really do.
I just don't…
I don't know how long
it's going to take me
to get over this.
Take all the time you need.
If you choose
to be vulnerable around me,
then I choose to be
vulnerable around you.
I'm just wondering
if, subconsciously,
you might be pushing me away
because you say that
you want this
and you say that
you want us, but…
-But do you?
-Where is this coming from?
Well, if mojo-wise,
you're no longer
letting me in,
If now you're… invulnerable
all the time,
doesn't that mean you're…
no longer choosing to
be vulnerable with me?
You deserve to hear
those three words back.
I'll never be able
to say them to you.
There's no way
you're incapable of love.
No one is incapable of love,
no one.
Azrael!
With the angel of death
at our side, I can't lose.
I'm sorry, Lu.
No.
I got it!
Chloe!
No, no, no.
This is all my fault.
I love you.
I'm going to get her back!
Lucifer, come on.
Your banishment. You'll die
if you try to go to heaven.
So be it.
Lucifer,
what are you doing here?
I've come to get you.
It's not your time.
You need to come back.
The… the war and…
-Yes.
-And I left Trixie.
-And my friends.
-Yeah.
And I left you.
Ok. Wait!
How do we get back?
I'm not sure we can.
I'm afraid there's
not enough power left
for the both of us.
I choose…
you because…
I love you.
Lucifer.
Lucifer!
We have a daughter.
What if it's because
you've become God?
No.
No, no. My father
chose to be distant.
I would never choose this.
When Rory said that
you weren't at my deathbed,
you know, I still had that…
That's impossible.
Lucifer would never
abandon me.
But, reading this,
I realise…
Of course you would.
You've done it
so many times before.
-Have I?
-Yes!
Every time we've had
an emotional breakthrough,
you've immediately gone off
and disappeared.
And now
you've told me you love me,
it's…
the biggest breakthrough
we've ever had.
So I just wonder
how do I know
you won't follow it up with…
My biggest ever
disappearing act.
Today's the day.
What day?
August 4th.
The day that
Rory says you disappear.
I know this is
what I'm meant to do
and I know
that it feels right.
It's my calling.
Lucifer.
-Well, maybe I don't need--
-Lucifer.
Listen.
If you're feeling
any doubt at all,
remember that we are doing
this for Rory's sake.
I don't want to leave you.
I don't want you to leave,
either.
You can't see me.
But I'm right here.
And it'll be the same
down there.
No matter where you go.
No matter where you are.
I'll be with you.
I'll be with you always.
I'm going to miss you,
honey.
Mum, I'm an angel, remember?
I'll see you
on the other side.
It's a date.
Are you ready to go home?
Hello, detective.
I thought
you could use a partner.